The idea of slowing down the ageing
process and living healthier,
more productive lives
is hugely appealing.
It's led to a growing trend for
people looking to take control
of their own biology,
optimising their bodies
and minds through biohacking.
But how safe and ethical is it?
And are there more natural ways
of boosting your biology?
In this film, we're going to hear
from both the biohackers
trying to push human health
and wellbeing to its limits,
and those taking more traditional
scientific approaches.
Dave Asprey is an American
entrepreneur
and the self-described
father of biohacking.
I fully expect, and this
is not a made-up number,
to live to at least 180 years old
unless something like a tree
falling on me takes me out.
A lot of people ask, can we really
hack the ageing process?
And we are now on the cusp,
with literally about 50
different innovations to control
biology of ageing coming online
all at the same time.
And I have 100% certainty
that within a few years,
our new innovations that come in
happen faster than our ageing.
It's certainly true that the
scientific understanding of ageing
has progressed rapidly in recent
decades, but why is that?
I think one of the really big
surprises that's come along
about ageing
is how malleable it is.
There are... Especially in animals.
And I think what's come as
a huge surprise is that sometimes
the same thing will extend
the healthy lifespan of a fly
but also of a mouse.
And what that's telling us,
of course, is that some
of the underlying mechanisms of
ageing that we're interfering with
are in common
between these animals.
So I think that's why ageing has
opened up, really, to research
in recent years - the discovery that
we can use these short-lived things
where we can get the answers
more quickly to understand
what's going on in the creatures
that we really care about,
particularly ourselves.
As the science of ageing and
longevity becomes more advanced,
we're learning how to
not just slow down gradually
the effects of ageing, but truly
reverse many aspects of ageing.
We believe the cells in our bodies
have youthful information
when we're born and over time
they lose that information.
We've discovered that
there's information in the cell
to reset the system in the way
that you could reboot a computer
with fresh software.
For example, we've recently
reprogrammed the eye of an old mouse
to be young again and those
old mice get their vision back.
And that's just the beginning,
I believe, of being able to turn
the clock back, literally, to make
younger tissues in the body.
There are several companies within
the growing longevity industry
who are working on developing
regenerative therapies
to combat the diseases of ageing.
One such company is Elevian,
who are investigating how a protein
found in young blood
might have surprising
regenerative capabilities.
Our co-founders were part of a team
that really made some
important discoveries - that young
blood can rejuvenate aged animals
and vice versa - aged blood can
accelerate ageing in young animals,
and out of that work, they
identified this little known factor
called GDF 11 that decreases with
age, and what we and other labs
have now found is that a very
similar dose range of GDF 11
can be used to treat
and prevent dozens
of age-related diseases.
This research,
which originally began on mice,
is still in its early
pre-clinical stage.
Any drug development process
which arises from it
has to be thorough,
which can take years.
Elevian estimate that they are
about a year away
from beginning human
clinical trials.
For those impatient to slow down
their ageing process
and not keen to take part
in experimental trials,
there are steps that people
can take in their daily lives.
In many ways, our fight during
ageing is in our own hands already.
It's really clear that if you can,
you should take as much exercise
as is healthy,
and also eat a healthy diet
and not eat too much.
Dr David Sinclair believes
certain stresses on the body
can actually be good for longevity.
If you do the things that trick
the body into thinking
times could be tough -
short bouts of skipping meals,
so hunger, fasting,
but also losing your breath.
So running on a treadmill, doing
a lot of heavy weight lifting.
We also think that these are another
way to promote the body's defences.
And the combination of all of
those things actually is known
to extend lifespan by keeping
people healthier for longer.
Some biohackers are determined
to go further
and are willing to trial
experimental therapies
on their own bodies.
I decided that I wanted to try
every extreme intervention I could -
the stuff that billionaires
are doing,
so that I could write about it
and so that I could benefit from it.
I've had my bone marrow taken out,
spun down to get stem cells
and reintroduced the stem cells
throughout my body.
There's 150 supplements a day
that are part of my regime
but no-one really needs to do that.
I am a guinea pig to see
which ones work
and I'm constantly experimenting.
There are different degrees
of how far people want to go
to slow down their ageing process.
The most advanced I've ever seen,
if you want to call it advanced,
was there are a few people
that have tried reprogramming
their body with gene therapy
and giving themselves hormones
that are delivered by DNA.
To me, that's a risk.
I definitely wouldn't go there
because these effects
are irreversible,
and if there was
a cancer-causing issue,
then, really, you're not
going to live longer, right?
There is scepticism among many in
the mainstream scientific community
around the role that
biohackers can play
in better understanding our biology.
Do the risks of this
self-experimentation
outweigh the potential rewards
or is there a middle ground
that could help to push
the boundaries of optimising
our health?
The idea of allowing for...
..more use of experimental therapy
under informed consent
in a way that all data
must be shared
so that we as a community
can learn from it,
I think that's a really
exciting idea.
Biohacking has become a global
movement and we are out there
asking the hard questions
and doing the things
that a lot of scientists
would like to do
but they're not allowed to do,
because we still have autonomy
over our own bodies.
And when we talk about our results,
when we share them online,
scientists see them
and go, "Interesting",
and then that provides fuel
for studies.
The problem becomes when
people start doing things
which are not evidence based.
You know, for which the information
really just isn't out there.
Then I think obviously, you know,
as with anything else,
it can get dangerous.
If you don't have the information
on which to base a decision
to do something but you go
ahead and do it, I mean,
that's risky by definition.
I think somewhere in between there
is a happy intermediate.
I'm a scientist so I like to see
what happens to my body
when I do X, Y or Z,
but of course I'm very careful.
I measure what happens
and make sure that I'm hopefully
not doing myself any harm.
Many of those trying to hack
the ageing process
are also interested in trying to
optimise their immune systems.
In fact, there are biohackers
experimenting with procedures
such as faecal transplants - taking
someone else's poo as a medicine
in an attempt to cure
a range of ills.
Though less extreme, supermarkets
and pharmacy shelves
are heaving with so-called immune
boosting pills and supplements.
But is it even possible to alter
how the body responds to disease
through consuming someone else's poo
or by eating a blueberry pill?
And what are the risks?
The immune system is part of
an interconnected system
running all the way through our
body, involving all our tissues,
from our skin all the way
through to our toes.
And in fact, the gut has one of
the largest resident populations
of immune cells in our body.
Most of the body's immune cells
are found in the lining
of the intestine, and the microbes
in our gut play a crucial role
in keeping those immune cells
of our body healthy.
They do that by providing
the key chemical signals
that they get once they digest
the good foods that we eat.
So a healthy gut microbiome
is obviously crucial
to a healthy immune system.
The immune system is considered
to be an organ, but unlike every
other organ in your body, it's one
where components of the system
can migrate around the body.
You don't expect that with cells
from your lungs or your spleen
or any other solid organ,
but the beauty of the immune system
is it has a property
of immuno-surveillance.
Immunological surveillance is when
the cells of the immune system
come together to co-ordinate
a response to an external threat
such as disease.
For example, your lymph nodes -
the glands that swell up
when you are sick - are a sign
of your immune system at work.
We often hear messages encouraging
us to boost our immune system.
So, could we just take a pill
to do that?
When you do meet
an infectious threat,
our immune response has to react
quickly to contain the threat
and eradicate it,
and you don't want it to stay on
because if it stays on,
it's damaging.
And that is what happens in allergy
and autoimmune disease,
which are overactivity
of the immune response.
So there is no wonder pill
that's going to restore and boost
one part of the immune response
to help us be super-powered
because it's also interconnected
and the risks of getting it wrong
are really quite dramatic.
So, instead of boosting
our immune system,
we should focus on supporting it.
Everything that we know already
which is good for our health
will also benefit our immune system.
More exercise
taken at regular intervals
has been shown to boost
your immune function.
That's been shown
and that's published data.
Unfortunately, the modern
lifestyle is not very good
for our immune system.
Our diets of convenience foods and
fatty foods that are low in fibre
alongside sedentary lifestyles
with little exercise,
high stress and not too much
sleep, too much screen time.
All of these combine
to make our immune response
not work as it should.
Getting enough sleep
and reducing stress
can help our immune system
operate at an optimal level.
And even though one blueberry
won't work miracles,
getting a variety of the right foods
is very important.
To help your immunity, you need
to be feeding up your gut microbes,
and the best way to do this
is to make them more diverse,
give them more species.
And I recommend 30 different
types of plant a week,
which gives you all the fibre
you should need.
Secondly, you should pick plants
to eat that are high in polyphenols.
These are the chemicals that
are naturally found in plants
and are actually rocket fuel
for your gut microbes.
So things like brightly
coloured berries,
strong flavours like coffee beans,
dark chocolate
and even red wine
contains polyphenols.
So if what you eat and your gut is
so important for your immune system,
why are some people
transplanting other people's poo
into their own stomachs?
Faecal microbial transplant,
or, colloquially, a poo transplant,
is taking a sample of a stool
from a normal person
and putting it into someone
who's unwell.
This has been done for several
decades for very bad infections
of the bowel
like Clostridium difficile
and it cures 90% of people,
and it's since started to be used
on a number of other conditions.
This is a fascinating area
of research
but definitely not to be tried
at home, says Tim.
I think this is an exciting new form
of therapy, but it's always best
to do this within the confines
of a medical clinic
where things can be supervised
and the risk of side-effects
or infection is extremely low.
There are some people who take
risks and do do it at home
and those risks will be
multiplied considerably.
There's a lot of hype
about faecal transplants
and you mustn't believe people
who say that it works
in everything, in everybody,
it certainly doesn't,
and there are many failures
in clinical trials.
One of the ways we can effectively
and safely manipulate
our immune responses
is through vaccination.
What a vaccine is doing
is essentially giving you
the parts of the germ that will
stimulate the immune response
without actually getting
the full-blown infection.
Another thing that we can do
is actually try to switch
the immune response off.
For some diseases, we don't want
a powerful immune response
because that's what's causing
the damage.
This is exactly what's done
in diseases
like rheumatoid arthritis,
multiple sclerosis,
or is also being investigated
in infections like Covid.
The good news is, whilst there's
no one magic pill we can take
to optimise our immune response,
the more scientists learn
about how our immune system works,
the more they can develop
new drug treatments and therapies
to combat a wide range of diseases.
The knowledge of science is actually
leading to all sorts of wonderful
new possibilities to help treat us
and win the war against infection.
As well as optimising our bodies,
many of us are also interested
in boosting our brains.
In fact, for centuries,
people have looked for ways
to increase their intelligence,
concentration and creativity
through nootropics,
or cognitive enhancers.
If you're currently sipping
on a skinny latte,
you're consuming a form
of nootropic right now.
Caffeine is a stimulant and famous
for its ability to perk you up.
But so-called smart drugs
are gaining popularity.
There's now a huge market for
over-the-counter supplements
which claim, with very little
scientific evidence,
to boost concentration and memory.
Some people go even further and
seek out prescription stimulants,
such as modafinil, in a bid to
improve performance at work
or while studying.
A 2017 study based on
the Global Drug Survey,
an anonymous questionnaire,
showed that 30% of Americans
had taken some kind of smart drug
in the last 12 months.
That was up from 20% in 2015.
And they're not alone.
Large increases were reported
across Europe as well.
But do these drugs actually work?
And what are the risks?
Hanneke den Ouden
is a cognitive neuroscientist
at the Donders Institute
for Brain Cognition and Behaviour
at Radboud University.
Her lab has been studying how
the state of our brain's chemistry
shapes how we act.
So, modafinil is in a category of
drugs classed as psychostimulants.
Other examples are methylphenidate
and, for example, amphetamine.
And psychostimulants act generally
in a way to enhance activity
in your dopamine system.
Raised levels of a neurotransmitter
called dopamine
can stimulate signals
in the parts of your brain
associated with concentration
and focus.
It also helps to reduce hyperactive
and impulsive behaviours.
This is incredibly useful
for people with ADHD, for example,
but it's also finding its way
illegally into the hands
of those without a diagnosed
medical condition.
In some recent studies, we've
looked at how psychostimulants
affect decision making
in a young, healthy population,
so not patients who are taking
these for treatment.
Specifically, we study
methylphenidate.
This is a drug that's maybe
better known
by the brand name Ritalin
or Adderall.
And what we found was that
methylphenidate makes you better
across a number of tasks,
and we think this might be the case
because we experience these tasks
as less, kind of,
cognitively effortful.
But, says Hanneke, taking
these brain-boosting drugs
without a medical prescription
is risky.
All medications have a risk
of side-effects
and there's a reason that these
are prescription drugs.
So when we run a medication study,
for example, using psychostimulants,
we really extensively screen
our participants.
We actually get a doctor to sign
off on prescribing people
even a single pill. We often
give people only a single dose.
We know, for example, that
psychostimulants increase
your heart rate, and this can pose a
risk for people who have underlying
heart problems like arrhythmia
that they may not even know about.
Drugs don't affect everyone
in the same way.
Drugs will help some people
really well
and they will not help others
at all.
And this is really the Holy Grail
of psychiatry.
It's been for decades, probably.
How can we predict
what drugs work for whom?
Hanneke says there have been
virtually no studies
on the long-term cognitive effects
of psychostimulant use
in non-patients, but boosting
the dopamine levels in the brain
could cause long-term problems.
So, I talked about this finely tuned
balance of our brain chemistry,
and when you disturb that system
by adding a lot of dopamine,
then the system may in response,
to try to regain that balance,
turn down its sensitivity
to dopamine.
And so you could become dependent
on taking the medication
to kind of get to your normal
levels of your system.
And then finally there's another
risk, and this is maybe even more
speculative but I think also
very important to think about,
is that being really focused
all the time
is not necessarily the optimal
state for all situations.
We do know that being super-focused
may actually reduce our creativity
and our openness to new ideas
or out-of-the-box solutions,
and so I think that we
don't want a society
of just hyper-focused people.
Rather than boosting your brain
power through medication,
there's growing evidence
that it can be boosted
through more natural means -
namely meditation and mindfulness.
So how does that work?
One consequence of being human is
the fact that we have these minds
that can kind of wander off
and think about
all kinds of weird stuff, right?
This is Laurie Santos.
She's a professor of psychology
at Yale
and teaches a course called
the Science of Well-Being.
The research shows that
the simple act of meditating,
even, like, ten minutes a day
if you're a novice,
can significantly reduce
brain activation
in regions of your brain
that tend to mind wander.
So it's literally changing the
kind of default firing patterns
of your brain just through
this simple act of meditating.
So why is mind wandering
not so good?
Laurie says research shows
that when our mind wanders,
it can make us unhappy.
The irony is that we're never fully
present, right, and the enjoyment
that we get out of simple actions
in life, whether that's eating
something delicious or doing the
dishes or talking with a friend,
we really need to be present
for that to kind of kick in.
We need to be there to savour it
and notice it.
And this means that this act
of mind wandering
seems to significantly decrease
our wellbeing over time,
and that's why practices like
meditation can be so powerful.
Meditation in a variety
of different forms.
At least one of the benefits is
that it kind of trains our mind
to be a little bit more present
than is typical.
Not only does meditation
stop the mind wandering,
it also builds up more connections
between parts of the brain.
It effectively rewires your brain
away from mind wandering
and towards the present.
And the effect lasts, according to
a 2008 study, which found people
who had practised meditation were
happier even eight weeks later.
Meditation doesn't just
help us enjoy life.
A 2013 study by the University
of California showed that a course
of meditation actually
boosted test scores.
It also has a host of other
benefits, says Laurie.
It increases concentration.
It increases our memory over time.
It has lots of physical health
consequences.
You can see improvements in
immune function after meditation
and things like that.
You know, these kind of markers
of ageing and things like telomeres,
those kinds of markers
seem to get better
for people who regularly meditate.
So if there are signs that it aids
your brain power, happiness,
immune function and even DNA,
would it be too much
to talk about meditation
as some kind of remedy
for the human condition?
Sometimes people talk
about this question -
is meditation sort of a panacea?
And honestly, as a scientist,
we usually kind of get
a little worried when we see things
that have all these benefits,
but meditation just seems to be
one that, empirically speaking,
just does have so, so many benefits.
So there you have it.
It is possible to optimise
our bodies and our brains.
Whilst DIY faecal transplants
and the use of non-prescribed
psychostimulants are definitely
not to be recommended,
there are clearly other things
that can help many of us,
from vaccinations to meditation
to regular old exercise,
and even though living to 180
will probably not be attainable
or even desirable, as the scientific
understanding of our bodies grows,
the hope is that many of us
will be able to look forward
to longer, healthier and happier
lives in the future.